The internet as you know it
it is under attack
and it's more fragile
than you might think.
(Dial-up sounds)
In the earlier, nerdier,
screechier days of the net
the possibilities seemed endless.
"Information wants to be free,"
said the Web 1.0 pioneers.
They envisioned a free internet
where countless independent nodes
would sustain a worldwide system
of instant communication,
entirely decentralized and therefore
immune to central control or sabotage.
Cut to today, and ehh, I think they
got it about half right.
So much for independent,
it now seems like the internet
and its infrastructure
are owned by the same
three American dudes.
In a world of mega-platforms,
attention-sapping algorithms
and mass surveillance,
we aren't wondering
if information is free,
we're wondering if we are.
Now with all the doom and gloom aside,
I should say I love the internet.
It's where I spend most of my time.
The best thing about my pandemic
has been watching the rest of you
get reduced to my level.
(Laughter)
It's accelerated the digital world's
invasion of the material one.
That meeting that could have been an email
is now an email.
Malls are being shut by search bars.
Fortnite tournaments
are filling national stadiums
and JPEGs are selling
for the price of a da Vinci.
Whatever happens next,
we're all going to be spending
more time online.
So how do we protect what makes it great
and change what makes it terrifying?
Well, first of all,
I think we need an update.
Internet access is no longer a luxury.
It is a necessity for economic
and individual development.
For developing countries, increased access
is a pathway out of poverty
and enables smoother access
to essential services
like education and health care.
As millions in the Global South
have logged on,
the way the world accesses the Internet
has completely changed.
In 2011, mobile internet use
accounted for just 5% of total traffic.
Today, it sits comfortably at 56%.
Cheap phones and 4G
have made the internet truly global,
but it also means that most of us
only access it through
a handful of applications.
The internet is in all of your pockets
and this is a TED Talk,
so it's probably on most of your wrists.
Not mine. I've got a calculator.
(Laughter)
Keeps me humble.
That’s where we access it,
but we wouldn’t be able to
if it weren't for unassuming,
securely guarded buildings like this one.
Internet exchange points
where bandwidth is actually produced.
If these places cease to operate,
then the internet is down
and not even the sweatiest guy
in your IT department
can do anything about it.
In 2011, the Egyptian government
shut down one of the country's
two main exchange points,
the Ramses Exchange in Cairo.
The internet was being used
to organize protests
as users were galvanized by sharing videos
of ongoing violence in real time.
For days, only a few government ministries
and the stock market
were connected to the internet.
It was a threat to the crumbling regime.
And when the government did fall,
the internet got
the lion's share of the credit.
Protests were organized
without appointed leaders
and with unprecedented speed.
And this is what the internet does
that no other technology
has ever come close to achieving:
decentralized mass organization.
Since then, though,
regimes have gotten a lot better
at harnessing the internet's
power for themselves.
In 2019, both Iran and Iraq
faced potentially destabilizing
protest movements,
and both governments reacted
by pulling the national router.
These blackouts, though, are costly.
Iraq's 11-day shutdown
was estimated to cost their economy
over 2 billion dollars.
Iran's only lasted eight days,
but the communication blackout
was used to imprison organizers
and murder protesters in the hundreds.
Video of violence made its way online
once access was restored,
but by then, the protest movement
had lost all momentum.
This year, the frontline fight
for the free internet has been in Myanmar.
The military junta
seized power in February
and enacted nightly internet shutdowns
to hinder protest
and hide human rights abuses.
Social media was banned for months,
but activists have been successfully
skirting restrictions using VPNs
to access restricted services
and to document state violence.
This is guerrilla cyberwarfare in action
and it has real world casualties.
Mobile phones might be
empowering the resistance,
but they are also facilitating
data-driven mass surveillance.
Use the wrong platform
and the government
can monitor your private messages
and automatically delete them
before they reach
their intended recipient.
To me, this is like halfway between
the government censoring your mail
and your thoughts.
But it's not hopeless.
Just before the junta took over,
their arrival was documented
in this viral video
by a fitness influencer.
(Upbeat music)
That is the junta's top brass
arriving in the background
to depose the democratically
elected leader.
Now I love this video.
It's simultaneously absurd and tragic,
which I feel like are the twin moods
of the internet at the moment.
But it also shows
that even when the entire
national infrastructure of the internet
is controlled by a repressive regime,
information still wants to be free.
In the West, though,
some of us are worried
that information has gone a bit too free.
In some cases, fact-free.
Disinformation and misinformation
on social media
are testing the boundaries of free speech.
The World Health Organization
has called the pandemic an infodemic,
with their official updates
sharing a timeline
with posts telling you
to cure coronavirus by drinking bleach.
In the UK, a conspiracy theory
linking 5G to coronavirus
spread so quickly that it led
to over 30 arson attacks on cell towers
in March 2020 alone.
Absurd. Tragic, once again.
But it's easy to see there's a problem.
Combating disinformation is tricky
when mega-platforms
have become so enormous
that they're nearly impossible
to effectively moderate.
When Facebook attempted
to use machine learning
to identify and remove dangerous posts,
it often couldn't tell the difference
between government guidance
and posts meant to mimic it.
Imperfect machines
ultimately create imperfect machines.
So this is a very human problem
and it obviously outdates the internet.
There's always been demand
for disinformation.
It's based on what people want to believe.
And where there is demand,
there is opportunity to supply.
Facebook themselves will tell you
that most disinformation on their platform
is financially incentivized.
Malicious actors who own
small websites crammed with ads,
who will pay to advertise
on Facebook first to get the ball rolling.
Platforms might not be able
to moderate everything we say
and I don’t think they should,
but they are more than capable
of disrupting and regulating
who pays them.
Of course, mega-platforms resist
any regulation of their advertising
because it's where they make
most of their money.
We all know they aren't
selling us a service.
They're selling access to our eyeballs.
There's now a widespread distrust
of the unregulated Internet.
In the UK, there has been
popular public campaigns
and subsequent government proposals
to connect social media accounts
to government-issued identification,
getting rid of the anonymity
and holding people accountable
for all the naughty things
they say online.
This is well-meaning,
but it's a fucking terrible idea.
Marginalized groups
and political dissidents
rely on anonymity
to protect their free speech,
and having your government ID
connected to your social media account
would leave you extremely vulnerable
to phishing scams and identity theft.
I don't share my name online
or anywhere publicly,
not because I'm shy,
but because I'm just curious to see
how long I can keep it up.
Gaining notoriety but retaining anonymity
is a unique privilege
of the information age,
so why not take advantage of it?
The internet is difficult to tame
because it was built that way.
This is Jon Postel,
a man who once held the unofficial title
of “God of the internet.”
Here he is posing in front
of a hand-drawn map of it in 1998.
The US government had contracted Jon
to run the root authority
of the Domain Name System,
the closest thing
the internet's infrastructure has
to the top of its hierarchy.
Basically when you type in twitter.com
or paymytaxes.gov,
the root authority
is what makes sure you get there.
That's an oversimplification,
but what you need to understand
is that whoever controls
the root authority
controls access to every website
and theoretically
could delete all of them.
So when the US government asked Jon
to hand control over,
he said no.
And this one act of resistance
would lead to the creation of ICANN,
an international multistakeholder group
that ensures the global internet
can't be controlled
by a single company or government.
Naturally, some governments
have resisted this.
Notably, the Chinese government
have been advocating
for what they call
internet sovereignty since 2013.
This is the idea
that each country has the right
to control a separate version
of the internet within their own borders.
Of course, China's internet
has worked this way for decades,
but it's increasingly
an attractive option to others.
Iran booted up their own version in 2018,
and Russia are quietly testing theirs out.
And these national firewalls are used
to restrict unwanted information,
but their main priority
is to crush organization
that happens outside
of a party political structure.
And frankly, if it is disinformation
that we're worried about,
governments are the last group
we should trust with regulating it.
In 2018, Facebook COO Sheryl Sandberg
claimed that the company deleted
over 1.3 billion fake accounts
in just six months.
A few hundred million of them
were probably cooked up here,
in the old Saint Petersburg office
of the Internet Research Agency,
a private company owned
by a close friend of Vladimir Putin
and a state-funded troll army.
Their job is to spread disinformation
and sow discord online
with a phantom army of puppet accounts
and conspiracy theories.
Their job isn't to bolster
the argument of one side,
but to inflame debate and make
all sides look equally ridiculous.
But this nihilistic genre of propaganda
is incredibly weak
when it's confronted
with the sincerity of outsiders.
That's why I think Alexei Navalny
is the most interesting person
on the internet today.
If you don’t know who he is,
he’s a lot of things:
a dissident, lawyer, criminal and YouTuber
who took on the Russian government.
His video on Putin's palace
got 120 million views,
which inspires professional awe
and jealousy in me.
And aside from some
high-budget drone shots,
there is very little
new information in this video.
It's a compilation
of previously available sources,
sometimes decades-old information.
But unlike these old sources,
this video reached
25 million people in 24 hours
and delivered this information
in an exciting,
hilarious and inclusive way.
After surviving an assassination attempt
and being sentenced to a penal colony,
Navalny is still leading
resistance online.
The Kremlin have duly blocked
access to this video
and have blocked access
to Smart Voting websites,
which Navalny has been propagating.
We might be frightened of mega-platforms,
but they are empowering individuals
and giving outsiders an audience
that dwarfs the one offered
by legacy media establishments
that dominated the information market
during the last century.
And I know it feels like
we're spending our lives
flicking between the same four apps,
and that's because we are.
Around 80% of internet traffic
is captured by only
a handful of companies
and we're spending
progressively more time with them.
Thanks to lockdown and home working,
internet use in the UK
doubled in just one year.
And all of those Netflix binges
are putting a strain
on the internet's infrastructure.
This is a hyperscale data center.
There's around 600 of them worldwide
and over half of them are owned
by either Amazon,
Microsoft, Google or Apple.
The number of these
computer cabinet labyrinths
has doubled in the last five years
to keep up with our
ever-increasing demand.
And this has upset
internet service providers
who claim that these
bandwidth-hogging companies
aren't paying their fair share.
And maybe they aren't.
And while I do think it is concerning
that so few companies
control so much of the internet,
I don't think their reign is assured.
Internal projections at Facebook
show that teenagers are abandoning
their platform in their droves,
so much so that their American user base
could decrease by up to 45% in two years.
I'm not saying that the problem
will solve itself.
These platforms are powerful,
but only in proportion to the time
and attention that we give them.
It's easy to forget that the internet
is still in its infancy
and new competitors
are gathering in every corner.
Then there are competitors
like the super apps.
And these apps are interesting.
They're mobile-only,
mostly an Asian phenomenon so far.
They are applications that position
themselves as a one-stop shop
for all your internet-based needs.
Singapore has Grab, Indonesia has GoTo,
but by far the most popular
is China's WeChat.
With over 1.3 billion active daily users,
WeChat has integrated itself
into the fabric
of normal social life in China.
It's your driver's license,
your debit card and your phone.
It's where you pay your landlord,
book flights, hotels
and doctor's appointments.
It has supercharged China's journey
towards a cashless society,
replacing coins with QR codes,
with even the homeless forced to upgrade.
And it is a brilliant tool.
It has brought older generations
and the industrial working class online
and given them easier access
to essential services.
But it also conveniently bundles up
all of your personal data,
private messages and physical whereabouts
for a government with backdoor access.
The surveillance enabled
by these super apps
is threatening to turn privacy
into a relic of the 20th century.
Because when there's only one platform,
there's nowhere left to hide.
The internet was built to be plural,
to exist nowhere in particular
and to be accessible everywhere.
Internet culture is global culture,
arguably the first ever instance of it,
and we must ensure
that everyone has equal access.
No one in this room knows
what the internet will look like
in ten, 50 or 100 years,
but we can be damn sure it'll be here.
It's the greatest invention
of all of our lifetimes,
and we must ensure
that it reflects the best of us.
It must be open, enquiring, cooperative
and suspicious of authority.
Thank you.
(Applause)